so
this story is terrifying interview with
the Alabama man who spent 20 hours
treading water in the Gulf of Mexico
after he fell off of a cruise ship and
shredded water for 20 hours until they
found him holy [ __ ] 20 hours probably
from a cruise ship he's sharing his
incredible tale of survival and rescue
at Sea eat the pilgrim here with the
interview good morning Eva this was a
crazy story guys and you'll never guess
this George this just coming in here
you're gonna love this George the man
who saved him our very own Michael
Strahan we're gonna go to him with this
instead George hey how's everybody doing
he's got a brain Slicker on
what's that over there see I was doing
my usual daily 20 mile swim
and I saw him out there and I said this
apparently they called me a hero I was
out there swimming and I seen this man I
said what you doing out here it's crazy
you know you like to swim 20 miles
through Carnival told me I got free
cruises for life
ain't out here
skin is raw from the salt and swimming
somehow James Michael Grimes doesn't
have a broken bone or even a cut his
family says it's a Thanksgiving Miracle
when he already knows has changed his
life yeah that are you [ __ ] or he
just got replaced by a synth good boy of
course she didn't think about that she's
a synth
am I a synth I don't know there's no way
to know do like cut into your wrists
like in Westworld he's looking for the
chip yeah it was a Thanksgiving to
remember James Michael Grimes knows he's
lucky he's not a [ __ ] assassin
because he has three names be alive my
worst fear is drowning and that was
something I did not want to have to face
he was black but when he fell in the
water did you know that
the 28 year old going overboard a cruise
ship in the middle of the night saying
he spent about 20 hours Treading Water
how did you go over that's what I want
to know what were you doing because it's
not a silly little stunt were you trying
to do it's not easy to fall over a
cruise ship better alone in the Gulf of
Mexico I wanted to see my family now
was dead set on making it out of there
you know I was never accepting
but this is it this is going to be the
end of my life it was supposed to be a
Thanksgiving celebration James Michael
and 18 of his family members boarding
the Carnival Valor last Wednesday in New
Orleans we were just hanging out having
a good time watching some live music
somebody said how no hypothermia what
it's the gulf it's really nothing
yeah did you have a few drinks uh
I had during the day
drinking that's never good oh and let me
did you get because I know they have
this did you get the carnival you pay 70
bucks you get all the booze for the
entire trip too because that's a good
deal I wouldn't say no to it that's for
sure and don't worry they say they cut
you off but if you go to different bars
they don't keep count they don't cut you
off as long as you're tipping the third
world guy making your drinks they're not
cutting you off that actually did like
an air guitar solo
this guy rolls this guy rolls
your guitar solo way
and there's a competition and I'd won it
so I'd want a free drink
on top of all the other drinks so I had
that but this is him through the air
guitar solo contest there it is this is
the dude I I just had to look it up all
right so you guys want to know what
actually happened yeah I know what
happened sure [ __ ] he was at the bar
with his sister and him and his sister
were [ __ ] around and she pushed him
overboard an accident and she didn't
[ __ ] tell anybody
wait yeah what nobody nobody said it
nobody has said it but you notice how he
was just like yeah he never mentioned
his sister was there but his sister was
there okay
no his Christmas dinner is going to be
the [ __ ] lit yeah but but you hadn't
had like you weren't like inebriated had
like a ton of drinks or
maybe the reason he's not saying
anything is he probably did something
[ __ ] worse to her like punched her or
something and he didn't want like you
know he just it was kind of like okay
they're supposed to shut up
you know how many drinks do you think
you'd had uh hey we're like What are you
my [ __ ] sponsor like why don't you
hey really like on the drink thing I
have an idea why don't you calm down
somebody's in the middle of divorcing
like stop rejecting your misery onto
this guy what the [ __ ] is it the
drinking he's on it to be fair let me
defend it because you were drinking let
me defend this guy getting drunk on a
cruise ship is the point of going on a
cruise ship like you know what I mean
like I've been drunk on a cruise I've
never fallen over around 11 p.m that
first night on board James Michael told
his sister he was going to the bathroom
uh-oh what happened next is still
unclear
Virgie I think you nailed it let's see
what let's hold on let's see what he
said let's see let's see what he says
let's see what he says do you remember
leaving and going to find the bathroom
no no
do you remember
falling off the boat
oh yeah this is spoopy uh oh yeah you're
lying oh oh oh I wonder what really
happened so you don't know how it
happened no ma'am I came to regained
Consciousness I was in the water
with no boat in sight so
you for a while were passed out in the
water yes ma'am went from the drinking
was it the alcohol yes this woman has
some kind of like agenda against booze
what are you in mad and
I can't float myself even when I'm
trying to have you thought about
quitting drinking ma'am no I was in a
cruise I don't normally drink I was just
drinking because I was on a cruise
there had to be you know the Lord was
with me when I was out there was Jack
Daniels with you with Jack Daniels with
you out there too they say that God
protects everyone even the drunks and
the babies so like she's just she she
just keeps all right man
are you a drunk or a baby sir
are you a big drunk baby yeah This
Woman's just the worst
this is amazing
because something was holding me up the
whole time buoyancy yeah it's literally
it's it's your but you're dead your
body's density yes this is the density
of the water what do you think magic was
holding you up
I don't know man it's like a fell off
the boat but then I just started
floating on this wet stuff
camera Chris James Michael Grimes known
to friends it's grimy
yeah
miles passed out the next day when he
hadn't returned to his cabin his
everyone was relieved because they said
that guy's a real [ __ ] buzz kill oh
my God that guy sucks did you see he
kept throwing the guitar solo victory in
our face like the entire night he just
wouldn't let it go family alerted the
ship's crew at 2 30 more than 12 hours
after James Michael was last seen
Carnival notified his sister said hey
look so something happened
by the Coast Guard of a missing
passenger we did have a fairly
significant search area it was a
potential of over 7 000 miles of ocean
we had to search James Michael was alone
in an area known to be a feeding ground
for sharks I thought it was yeah the
ocean
the ocean the ocean is the feeding
ground for sharks ma'am it's where they
live
the great whites of the Serengeti no I
guess I haven't
it was a shark I mean I was swimming in
One Direction and I looked around and I
seen it at the corner of my eye and it
came up on me really quick and I went
under and I could see it
and it was there was no shark sir you
were drunk there was no shark I wasn't a
shark I don't believe but it had more
like a flat mouth and it came up and
bumped one of my legs and I kicked it
with the other leg it scared me not
knowing what it was or
at the time how big it was all I could
see was a fin the Avid Outdoorsman tried
to stay positive and calm exhausted and
hungry he ate what he could find to
maintain his energy what what do you
think hold on this story to me sounds
weird completely insane this completely
sounds like a lie from beginning to end
let me see what what he ate the stick
come floating by looked like bamboo so I
started eating on it
okay so he's [ __ ]
he he ate Driftwood in the ocean
it would look like bamboo so I started
eating all there sir the cruise ship
left New Orleans not not Hokkaido Japan
where were you finding bamboo in the
ocean
what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] guy he's a liar so I fell bamboo
and I fashioned a raft out of it and
then this whale came and I rode him back
to the boat
I'll stood on its back in a majestic
fashion as it rolled me back to safety
the sunset was beautiful
[Laughter]
actually his name was Willie and he is
free now and now I'm not gonna say it
tasted good but it gave some type of
flavor in my mouth other than Salt Water
but what did it also taste like salt
water because it was floating in salt
water
oh and mold
was there any point while you were out
there where you thought I wish I had
more booze you lush you big [ __ ] Lush
I I don't know how much longer I can
keep doing this well I was just hoping
that maybe like I don't know like a
Snickers bar would float up or something
I'd be able to eat one of them
started going getting back towards night
time again the Water started getting
colder
at that time I thought you know how much
longer am I going to have to be out here
what is he a water panda
water Panda water Panda That's What I
Call Filipinos yeah I was really hungry
and then this ham soaked in from floated
by
from him
oh
oh [ __ ] yes ma'am you know what the fall
didn't
kill me you know sea creatures didn't
need me I felt like I was meant to get
out of there as the sun was yeah we're
gonna go on to Greatness I can tell
God really has a plan for you yep
because the world did the world needs
another Pep Boys assistant manager
like God God saved his life so he could
put an old lady's windshield wiper
blades on for her yeah all right
Safelite guy Thanksgiving night James
Michael says he spotted a glimmer of
hope the lights from a tanker ship and
decided to swim towards it that was my
final
a little burst of energy the strength
that I had I used pretty much every bit
of it somebody says he's going to go on
an air guitar tour now professional air
guitarist try to make it to one of them
the Coast Guard then arriving his
miraculous rescue captured on camera
when the Coast Guard got there
yeah what happened uh I tried to eat the
Rope I thought it was some sort of
Twizzler I thought it was bamboo I think
everything is
I'm not gonna lie when I fell off the
boat I hit my head pretty hard he
circled the boat two or three times
looking for me
and you know I was
I've been taking off my socks and
everything it was just waving them
around my head trying to do something
where they would see me and when that
light finally hit me somehow I heard we
got him and I seen a guy coming down
from the helicopter and it was coming
towards me
you know right then I thought man this
is I See the Light When the Coast Guard
guy showed up in the water
what are you drinking is everybody
drinking alcohol I need to know did he
give you a beer did you have the shakes
from about having booze yeah did you
have the chance
laughs
what'd you say to him I said man can I
get a drink
and some family
also can I borrow your phone I gotta I
gotta get my money back from Carnival
because I paid for the whole booze
package and I fell in like halfway
through yeah first thing I want a day I
want to get a doc today I want to get a
day refund totem was I don't have any
clothes on
because I didn't I didn't strip out of
everything he said that's fine all right
I was just like okay
and he told me to hold on to this life
that's when I was just thinking thank
you you know you're like a guardian
angel coming down for me his Rescuers
believe he was seconds away from not
making it I spammed it as fast as I
could
um as I got to him I shoved the rest you
sling yeah that guy's in the Coast Guard
yeah that's about right that's about
that that is the code that is a mustache
there's somebody in the Coast Guard
I'll tell you what he's not in the real
military
leave them coasties alone I've seen them
do some pretty badass [ __ ] yeah what's
that [ __ ] drink at a bar and then hit
their wife because I've seen that well
that is pretty badass